okay now this suggests is it the orange
or the green one that's more likely
looks like the green one right you see
how it dips down in between these two
guys right now are you sure are you
positive is that like are you certain
that that's what it's going to do not
certain yet and sir you're certain okay
some of you are not yet okay why not I
mean just so we're really sure because
we're still like these are new objects
to us right consolers just to me another
point that might be useful negative one
we're going to try to try a negative one
so if I put it in right can you help me
out this will become negative one what
will this object become X minus 2 that's
negative 3 negative 1 times negative 3
times 2 negative 1 times negative 3
times 2 the two negatives will cancel so
I'm really doing 1 times 3 that's 6
isn't it 6 where's that going to be for
me somewhere up here right negative 1 6
right positive 6 yeah negative one goes
to the left and then 6 goes up X and
then Y yeah so interesting let's put
this on um according to my scale I'm
about here okay so I think before we
actually put the shape in I think we
roughly know where this is going now
don't we
okay you can see it's got to get up it's
got to go down and then it's going to
have to the whole shape exists because
your domain is have a look all revalue
of X there's no square roots there's no
division or anything like that breaking
things okay so I'm gonna put a line
through this okay I'm gonna go something
like this let's see
like so okay now this is weirdly even
though it's also a cubic right and I'm
now going to come to raster this
question right if I did expand this all
out the reason why I know it's going to
be cubic is there are one two three x's
right so if I went and did this I would
get y equals let's do this one first so
that's going to be x squared plus X
minus six x squared plus X minus six
how do that by the way how do I know
without like doing the first outside
inside last how did I know that was
going to be what it was when I if I gave
you an equation like this what would you
do to factorize this what would you do
you're looking for a pair of numbers
right based on the coefficients aren't
you you're going to search your a pair
of numbers that adds up to this and
multiply to this and those numbers are
three and two right well here I'm doing
that in Reverse and looking at these two
and I'm saying oh when you add those you
get one yeah I'm going into the reverse
order and when you multiply these you
get negative six right so now I'm going
to fish the expansive expansion this is
what I get you see my it's a cubic what
what is it that signals to me it's a
cubic in this line here it's the X cubed
and there's nothing higher than that
right there is an x squared that doesn't
make a quadratic because it's X cubes
kind of takes over right it's the most
important thing so this guy here is a
lot more complicated yeah this guy here
right well when you have a look at this
guy here which had no x squared term in
it and it didn't have an X term in it
either just went straight to the
constant right what happens is the x
squared and the X they change this shape
in here do you notice how this is much
simpler right do you agree and this this
like Wiggles around wildly and that
wiggling around happens because of these
terms in here okay
later on we're going to talk about
addition and subtraction of functions
that will become a bit more it will make
a little more sense when you think about
these three as three separate functions
and what happens when you put them
together but this is what you will end
up with okay sorry
that's okay all right now quick question
to you right um oh yeah did you come
back to you that's why I like questions
they would say they would say graph this
that would be the entire question graph
that write the equation of they could
totally do this in reverse order so for
example we're about to do that for
example I could give you this I could
give you this and we should be able to
sort of reverse engineer takes a bit
more thought but I should be able to
reverse engineer this out of that guy's
I want to hear strange question because
it might be relevant to all of us but I
can't hear it right now do you want go
ahead yeah so and you guys might feel I
certainly felt like this a lot when you
put words into there it becomes a lot
more tricky you have to interpret those
quite carefully and frankly even though
Matz
obviously is a lot about symbols and
equations and numbers the words are just
so important like that's why I talked
about when you put in a word like when
that's why we introduced language and
make such a big deal about it right the
language is like an integral part you
can't separate it out so it's just as a
new thing to understand within this okay
now I have one last point that I wanted
to make on this before I let you guys
have a bit more of a play without my
explicit guidance okay we have a look at
these parabolas right do you remember
this point here this point here the top
or the bottom of the parabola right it
has a special name of its own to
remember that we caught the vertex at
the vertex
now based on today's lesson you now know
it also has another name right do you
see that's kind of like a spot where the
graph is going down and then like it
stops for a minute and then it goes back
up so you can also call this a
stationary point right so we're going to
come back to this language do you have a
question yeah yeah ah now we also sits
like wait a second what is this thing
right what it what is its name is it a
tourney
is it a vertex is it a stationary point
and the answer is the answer is yes it
is all of these things right we call it
the vertex because that's kind of like
the the central point of the parabola
right it's also a turning point cuz it
turns around it turns around
is this a turning point does it turn
around it does not it like kind of is
going up then it's not straight but then
it just keeps on going up so it's not a
turning point but it is it does stop for
a minute
does pause yeah yeah that is exactly
what it's to it you could call it a you
could call it a resting point if you
like right but it's the same idea yes
now like I said like I promise we're
going to go much more into that language
when we develop calculus but it's
important to know what that point is
okay now being my real question though
did you notice this guy here has not one
but two points where it sort of pauses
right let me ask you this are those do
they look like stationary points to you
what is what stationary mean just kind
of stops for a minute another way to say
it is the gradient at that exact point
is zero does it I'm we will later on
develop tools to like do this properly
but does it look like it sort of is
going to have a great in zero at that
point so here's what I'm gonna do we're
gonna have to spend a lot more time this
later but I'm gonna give you a short
answer is which is at that point totally
does it totally stops it's stationary
there and stationary as an added bonus
this carries pointing out it also turns
there as well it doesn't it sort of goes
up and it down down and then up okay
here's the tricky thing right how did we
find that I'll come to you in a second
Rasim how do we find the vertex on a
proper because you're supposed to be
able to find that right how do you do it
[Music]
we looked at x equals minus b on to a
what is that what's the significance of
x equals minus b on to a what's that to
a parabola what is the significance of
that
it's from the quadratic formula but it's
not the whole thing it's only a little
part it has a name this object
ah it's right down the middle of the
parabola is it
it's the axis of symmetry okay does this
thing have an axis of symmetry hmm you
would say no why Zaki that's that's
that's a no from Zaki okay it's the it's
the what is it like a strange got talent
it's like there's the X okay
no I'm not happy okay there's gonna be a
mirroring of some kind there isn't
mirroring right oh it's like wow what do
I do with this thing right now here's
the thing right unlike here where the
vertex is really easy to find you just
like pop this in and just like
automatically gives you the vertex every
single time right the the vertices
that's the plural by the way these
vertices here they're harder to find we
have to develop a whole new branch of
mathematics to actually locate those now
for that reason being at this moment in
time you have not developed it yet you
actually don't need to know exactly
where they are
you might notice I drew them slightly
off those points I had before because I
can tell you right now these are not
exactly where they are right I in fact
at this moment I don't know where they
are
where it turns around it could actually
do this like that it could turn around
at a completely separate point and I'm
pretty sure in fact for these that it
does okay but we will develop the
machinery for how to locate those points
later on at the moment we don't need to
worry about their exact position because
you can't find them